everyone wants to talk about ulates
because it's the I think the the most
staggering of the battles and this is
what makes Ridley Ridley just to be able
to seamlessly weave all these things
together and see the geography of the
scene come together where you have the
horses and the Infantry rushing in from
the hillside it's really just practical
and we you know created our own water
tanks on the floor or we dug them out on
the side of the Airfield and they put
little you know fake ice this like you
know styrofoam white foam and and guys
are falling into the tanks you've never
seen a
of of a battle sequence like this and
then to have the scene right on the tale
of it with him toasting the Austrian
leader so awful but he makes light of it
in a way and he's so smug about it but
that's his character